GREAT REPORTING.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US THIS
MORNING.
>> DON.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>>> WE MENTIONED THE MANHATTAN
D.A. IS CONTINUING ITS
INVESTIGATION OF DONALD TRUMP'S
ROLE INTO HUSH-MONEY PAYMENTS TO
ADULT FILM ACTRESS STORMY
DANIELS.
DANIELS MET WITH PROSECUTORS IN
THE D.A.'S OFFICE WHILE KEY
WITNESSES, MICHAEL COHEN,
WITNESS MICHAEL COHEN TESTIFIED
BEFORE THE GRAND JURY FOR THE
SECOND TIME THIS WEEK.
SO JOINING US NOW FOR HIS FIRST
TV, ON TV OR IN-PERSON INTERVIEW
SINCE THOSE TESTIMONIES DONALD
TRUMP'S FORMER ATTORNEY MICHAEL
COHEN, AUTHOR OF THE BOOK
REVENGE HOW DONALD TRUMP
WEAPONIZED THE U.S. DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE AGAINST HIS CHRISTA,
THE HOST OF THE MEA CULPA
PODCAST AND BREAKDOWN PODCAST.
THANK YOU FOR WAKING UP EARLY.
YOUR OTHER INTERVIEWS HAVE BEEN
ON THE PHONE?
>> NO, MY OTHER INTERVIEWS WITH
THE DISTRICT --
>> I MEAN FOR TELEVISION.
>> YES.
>> SO SO THANK YOU.
21 OR 22 TIMES?
>> I MET WITH THE D.A.'S 20
TIMES FOR INTERVIEWS AND TWO
TIMES FOR GRAND JURY.
>> WHY ARE YOU COOPERATING WITH
THE GRAND JURY?
>> THAT WAS THE PLEDGE I MADE
WHEN I STOOD BEFORE THE JUDGE
AND SAID I WILL COOPERATE.
I DIDN'T NEED A 5K 1 AGREEMENT,
I WASN'T A PART OF A COOPERATION
AGREEMENT.
DEMOCRACY IS MORE IMPORTANT THAN
ANYTHING AND I KNOW IT SOUNDS
HOKIE, BUT MY GOAL IS TO ENSURE
THAT TRUTH COMES OUT AND THAT
TRUTH TO POWER IS TOLD.
>> IN AS FAR AS ON THE LIST OF
WITNESSES, DO YOU KNOW WHERE YOU
ARE?
ARE YOU THE LAST ONE OR TOWARDS
THE END?
>> I WOULD PRESUME THAT I AM.
I KNOW FROM READING THE SAME
REPORTS THAT YOU HAVE WHETHER
IT'S "THE TIMES" OR "WALL STREET
JOURNAL" THAT THERE HAVE BEEN
SEVEN OR EIGHT WITNESSES THAT
HAVE COME IN AND SPOKEN BEFORE
THE GRAND JURY.
I AM IN THE AWARE.
THAT'S THE ONE THING ABOUT THIS
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE.
THEY ARE REALLY QUIET ABOUT
EVERYTHING.
YOU DON'T GET ANY INFORMATION
ABOUT ANYTHING OTHER THAN WHAT
PERTAINS TO YOU.
>> SO LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT THE
QUESTIONS -- I KNOW YOU WANT TO
PROTECT THE INVESTIGATION, WHAT
ALVIN BRAGG AND HIS OFFICE IS
DOING HERE.
>> THEN WHY ASK ME THE QUESTION?
>> I JUST WANT TO SEE WHAT --
WHAT DID PROSECUTORS ASK YOU?
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US?
>> I CAN'T TALK ABOUT ANY OF
THE -- OBVIOUSLY, YOU KNOW THAT
ONE OF THEM DEALS WITH THE
HUSH-MONEY PAYMENTS.
I WILL TELL YOU THAT ONE OF THE
THINGS I THINK THAT WILL COME
OUT OF THIS INVESTIGATION OTHER
THAN THE POTENTIAL INDICTMENT OF
DONALD TRUMP IS A LOT OF
INFORMATION ABOUT HOW THE
SOUTHERN DISTRICT OF NEW YORK
DEALT WITH ME IN MY SPECIFIC
CASE.
NOW, WHAT'S DIFFICULT FOR ME TO
DO IS TO TALK WITH ABOUT MAY OWN
CASE BECAUSE PEOPLE SAY YOU ARE
PARTISAN TO YOUR OWN CASE AND
TRYING TO MAKE A POINT.
LIKE MY ATTORNEY, HE HAS BEEN
WITH ME IN THIS JOURNEY SINCE
DAY NUMBER ONE.
AND HE HAS SO MUCH INFORMATION
ABOUT THE WEAPONIZATION OF THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AGAINST ME
THAT THERE IS NOBODY ELSE THAT
KNOWS THE STORY BETTER.
>> OKAY.
SO YOU CAN'T REALLY -- YOU WON'T
TALK ABOUT THE SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS.
CAN YOU TAKE US INSIDE AND TALK
ABOUT THE PROCESS OF THE GRAND
JURY?
WHO IS INTERVIEWING YOU?
WHAT IS IT LIKE?
ARE THEY EACH ASKING YOU
QUESTIONS?
>> SO THERE IS A LEAD PROSECUTOR
IN THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE WHO HANDLED THE
QUESTIONING.
IT WAS LIKE -- IT WAS BEING ON
TRIAL.
YOU ARE SITTING IN THE FRONT.
THERE ARE 23 GRAND JURORS.
AND AT THE END OF THE
PROSECUTOR'S QUESTIONING, THEN
THE GRAND JURORS GET AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ASK YOU THEIR OWN
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS.
>> DID EACH OF THE 23 GRAND
JURORS --
>> I CAN'T SAY EACH AND EVERY
ONE, BUT FOR THE MOST PART,
YEAH.
>> WHAT TYPES OF QUESTIONS?
>> THOSE QUESTIONS ALL RELATE TO
THE TOPICS.
IT'S SO MUCH BETTER IF LANNY
DAVIS WAS SITTING HERE.
HE CAN SIT AND TALK TO YOU ABOUT
THESE SORTS OF ISSUES.
FOR ME I REALLY DO WANT TO THE
ARE THE PROCESS FOR TWO REASONS.
ONE, THAT WAS A PLEDGE I MADE TO
THEM.
MORE IMPORTANTLY, IF I GET
CALLED AS A WITNESS AT THE
TRIAL, I DON'T WANT ANYTHING
THAT I SAY NOW TO IMPEDE UPON
THAT ABILITY.
>> I UNDERSTAND THAT.
YOU ARE AN ATTORNEY.
YOU KNOW HOW THIS WORKS.
LET ME ASK YOU THEN, YOU MET
WITH THEM 20 TIMES AND THEN FOR
THE GRAND JURY TWICE.
SO THEY HAVE MET WITH OTHER
WITNESSES, INCLUDING KELLYANNE
CONWAY, HOPE HICKS --
>> DAVID PECKER, DYLAN HOWARD,
JEFF McCONNIE, DEBRA TARASOV --
>> AS YOU GO BACK TO -- AFTER
THEY HAVE SPOKEN TO THE OTHER
WITNESSES, DOES THAT INFORM THEM
AS TO WHAT THEY ASK YOU THE NEXT
TIME?
>> I DON'T KNOW HOW THEY RUN
THEIR PROCESS.
>> THEY ARE NOT ASKING THE SAME
QUESTIONS OVER AND OVER?
>> I DO.
TO RESPECT THEIR PROCESS, WHAT I
CAN TELL YOU IS THAT THEY ARE
QUESTIONING OF ME STARTED OUT AT
LIKE 35,000 FEET.
BY THE TIME THAT I HIT THE 20th
INTERVIEW, WE WERE DOWN TO LIKE
THREE FEET READY TO LAND.
THE GRAND JURY WAS THE ACTUAL
TAKEOFF BACK TO WE'LL CALL IT
ACCOUNTABILITIVILLE.
>> SO THE GRAND JURY QUESTIONS
ARE DIFFERENT THAN THE QUESTIONS
THAT THEY INITIALLY ASKED YOU?
>> THEY ARE ON THE SAME POINT,
BUT THEY ARE NOT EXACTLY THE
SAME.
>> OKAY.
STORMY DANIELS TESTIFIED IN
FRONT OF THE GRAND JURY AT LEAST
MET WITH THE GRAND JURY
YESTERDAY THROUGH --
>> I DON'T KNOW THAT.
>> YOU DON'T KNOW THAT?
>> TO NO.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK OF STORMY
DANIELS BEING BROUGHT INTO THE
PROCESS?
THAT'S A SURPRISE TO PEOPLE.
DOES THAT CHANGE THIS
INVESTIGATION?
DOES THAT SHOW YOU IT'S
RATCHETING UP, THAT AN
INDICTMENT IS IMMINENT?
>> IT DOESN'T BENEFIT DONALD FOR
STORMY DANIELS TO BE TALKING
ABOUT IT.
SO IF THAT HELPS THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S CASE TO GO FORWARD,
SO BE IT.
I DO KNOW AND I AM PREPARED TO
TELL YOU THEY HAVE A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF INFORMATION.
A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE ATTACKED MY
CREDIBILITY.
TRUTH BE TOLD, AT THE END OF THE
DAY THEY CAN ATTACK ME ALL THEY
WANT.
THIS CASE IS NOT GOING TO BE
PREDICATED ON ANY BUN
INDIVIDUAL, BUT RATHER IT'S
GOING TO BE PREDICATED ON THE
DOCUMENTS, THE EVIDENCE, THE
TEXT MESSAGES, THE EMAILS.
>> ALL RIGHT.
SO THAT -- BECAUSE DONALD
TRUMP'S ATTORNEY JOE TACOPINA IS
ATTACKING CREDIBILITY --
>> BEFORE YOU DO THAT --
>> I KNOW YOU ARE TALKING
ABOUT --
>> THAT'S HOW YOU ASK SOMEBODY
FOR A DOCUMENT.
>> ALVIN BRAGG ONCE SAID -- I
HOPE HE REMEMBERS THESE WORDS --
HE CAN'T SEE A WORLD IN WHICH HE
WOULD BASE A PROSECUTION OF
DONALD TRUMP ON THE WORD OF A
CONVICTED PUNCHERER AND FELON
LIKE MICHAEL COHEN.
HE IS STILL A CONVICTED
PUNCHERER, SOMEONE CONVICTED OF
LYING AND IT'S NOT ABOUT
VENGEANCE, IT'S ALL ABOUT
VENGEANCE FOR HIM.
>> I KNOW YOU ARE SENSITIVE AND
TAKE UMBRAGE TO THAT.
>> I WAS JUST TRYING TO POKE FUN
AT HIM.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK OF WHAT HE
SAID?
>> HE IS A FOOL.
WORSE THAN THAT, WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN -- AND AGAIN I HAVE BEEN
BY TRUMP'S SIDE SO LONG, I COULD
TELL YOU THE PLAYBOOK ON TO IT.
DONALD SENT HIM OUT IN ORDER TO
LIE IN ORDER TO CONTINUE WITH
THE NARRATIVE THAT ONLY DONALD
WANTED.
HE'S FAILED IN THAT.
AND SO SOON HE WILL GET CUT OFF
JUST LIKE SO MANY OTHERS WHEN
RUDY MESSED UP OR ALENA HOBBS
MESSED UP OR CORCORAN OR EASTMAN
OR THE OTHER ONES AND SEND THEM
ON THE WAY AND TACOPINA WILL BE
ONE OF MANY.
>> WHO ELSE CAN CORROBORATE WHAT
MICHAEL COHEN IS SAYING, WHAT --
>> CLEARLY EVERYONE.
YOU SEE, IT'S EASY TO TURN
AROUND AND TO SAY, OH, MICHAEL
COHEN'S A CONVICTED LIAR.
THAT HAPPENS TO BE TRUE.
I DID.
I PLED GUILTY TO 1001 VIOLATION.
I ACCEPTED THAT.
WHAT YOU NEED TO DO AND PUNDITS
THIS AND IT'S WRONG, YOU NEED TO
FINISH THE SENTENCE.
YES, I WAS CONVICTED.
I PLED GUILTY TO 1001 VIOLATION
BUT I DID IT AT THE DIRECTION OF
AND FOR THE BENEFIT OF DONALD J.
TRUMP --
>> OTHER STUFF OUTSIDE OF DONALD
TRUMP?
>> HOLD ON.
THAT'S TRUE.
BUT WE ARE TALKING ABOUT WHAT
TACOPINA WANTS TO CALL PERJURY
CHARGE.
WHAT I LIED ABOUT WAS THE NUMBER
OF TIMES THAT I SPOKE TO DONALD
TRUMP ABOUT A FAILED REAL ESTATE
PROJECT IN MOSCOW, TRUMP
TOWER/MOSCOW.
I STATE TODAY CONGRESS THE
NUMBER OF TIMES WAS THREE.
IN FACT, THE NUMBER OF TIMES WAS
TEN.
IF YOU THINK OR ANYBODY THINKS
THAT'S GOING TO STOP ME FROM
BEING A CREDIBLE WITNESS
CONSIDERING EVERYTHING THAT I
HAVE TOLD MUELLER, SEVEN
DIFFERENT CONGRESSIONAL
COMMITTEES, THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL, THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY,
AND SO MANY OTHERS, HAS ALWAYS
BEEN PROVEN TO BE TRUTHFUL AND
ACCURATE, WELL, SO BE IT.
>> YOU CAN STILL HAVE A POINT OF
VIEW, AN OPINION ABOUT THIS
WITHOUT GIVING ANYTHING UP.
HAVING SPOKEN AND MET WITH THEM
SO MANY TIMES, DO YOU BELIEVE AN
INDICTMENT IS IMMINENT?
>> I DO.
>> AND DO YOU -- WHEN DO YOU
THINK IT COULD HAPPEN?
SOONER RATHER THAN LATER?
>> LET'S HOPE IT'S SOONER RATHER
THAN LATER BECAUSE EVERYONE
NEEDS TO BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE, TO
THE SAME STANDARD OF THE LAW AND
THAT INCLUDES FORMER PRESIDENTS.
>> THANK YOU, MICHAEL.
>> APPRECIATE IT.